Shawn's made a lot of money yeah thank
God because I make this a lot easier not
to late the the pressure is off a little
bit I realized it went over like 220
million bucks and I think that's what
Good Will Hunting made and it's entire
thing you know and we haven't opened it
here yet so is that crazy to think about
for you like yeah I mean it's just it's
a relief you know honestly like like I I
don't normally play in this arena you
don't I mean like you're much smaller
and it's nerve-wracking it's
nerve-wracking like the Jason Bourne
movies are big but but they've gotten
bigger as they've gotten successful so
it's like you're kind of hedged a little
bit but like this is just like like me
me shaking stuff you know I talked to
Ben about it because you know for him I
mean he's in that stratosphere at Batman
world where the budgets twice what this
is right I'm nervous about this but uh
but yeah it's um it's not for the faint
of heart
definitely it's amazing there's a scene
in the movie where um you know he talks
about how you're a thief when you're
liar and you're always be then you get
upset and it made me think like there's
certain things in life
certain qualities that are really
important you know that maybe your dad
instilled in you and you then want to
instill in your children what are some
of those qualities for you not to be a
thief and a liar you know look I think
for you know you want your kids to have
as much self-esteem as possible so that
they make good decisions that are better
because you can't be there for every
decision right you just never going to
be able to police every decision so you
got to try to fill them with enough
wisdom and self regard and you know to
to to make good choices and you want you
want them to have integrity you know I'm
I want them to be good friends to other
people I want them to be reliable and
loyal and and good kind you know you
mentioned Ben and I you seem to have a
bunch of good friends around you talking
about kids George Roberts a great friend
of yours you must be super excited for
him yeah yeah yeah you know I was
working with him last fall and he pulled
me aside on set and I mean I just I
almost started crying I was so happy for
him in exile and then he was like yeah
and I was like how far along is she and
he goes you know eight weeks and I'm
like are you out of your mind like don't
tell anybody else would tell anybody
else I mean like like don't you know the
12 week rule like of course he doesn't
right I'm like just shut up man you know
and then ever you know four weeks later
I'm like we're good right we're good
so yeah I'm thrilled for him and and
he's like she's amazing she is she is he
hit the jackpot right I mean just on
every level she's just a remarkable
woman and they're going to be great
they're going to be awesome parents
those kids are lucky it's exciting so
obviously your event of the ocean series
a lot of people looking forward to ocean
date so you know in the the best part is
some of those nicknames like you know
you know you're the rookie George's the
idea man you know they have this little
idea so we're wondering for ocean's 8 if
you had to come up with a nickname for
say Rihanna and Hathaway and Cate
Blanchet what what nicknames would you
give them associated with their names oh
my god well Ted Griffin who wrote oceans
was is a brilliant screenwriter and he
had a long time because I mean okay
let's see even one off the top of your
head for one of them Kate I would just
put the legend the legend there yeah
because she is she's like a living
legend already and she's still young but
now I started working with her almost
twenty years ago and and she's just
awesome